l'anarchisme de gauche a la prétention
de vouloir changer la société plus
modestement l'anarchisme de droite
veille à ce que celle-ci n'écrase pas
l'individu
[Musique]
oui si l'on considère la guergis de
droite comme une forme de révolte
individuelle un état d'esprit une façon
d'être au monde davantage qu'une
idéologie ou une doctrine bien défini la
chaise de droite a un certain goût pour
la liberté et la transation il n'aime
pas trop les radars et les impôts mais
si elles respectent pas toujours le code
de la haute il a son propre code de
l'honneur l'anarchiste de droite est
avant tout un anticonformisme qui se
méfie de la morale commune on dirait la
bien pensante aujourd'hui il est un être
de paradoxes par exemple comme bernanos
il peut être à la fois profondément
chrétien est profondément anti clérical
se reconnaître dans le message du christ
mais se moquer des querelles anarchiste
de droite déteste les conventions
méprise les institutions mais respecte
la tradition elle se reconnaît dans une
certaine idée de la civilisation enfin
l'anarchiste de droite est un littéraire
un romantique sa droite n'est pas celle
des coffres forts
la droite de manière générale à laisser
le monopole des idées de la culture à la
gorge dans ces cas précis je crois aussi
parce que l'anarchisme de droite ce défi
justement des idéologies des théories
abstraites il dénonce l'enfermement de
certains penseurs de gauche dans le
monde des idées l'anarchisme de droite
ou l'anarchiste de droite et anti
dogmatique anti doctrinaire a contrario
l'anarchisme de gauche est une réelle
doctrine fondée sur la négation du
principe d'autorité dans l'organisation
sociale elle a pour but de parvenir à
une société sans classe par la
coopération entre les individus
l'autogestion la démocratie l'anarchisme
de droite est plus individualiste elle
n'a pas de grandes ambitions collectives
elle ne croit pas à l'existence d'un
prolétariat et rory l'anarchisme de
gauche a la prétention de vouloir
changer la société plus modestement
l'anarchisme de droite veille à ce que
celle-ci n'écrase pas l'individu lui
pauwels le fondateur du figaro magazine
qui sig dans notre série sur les
anticonformistes et qui peut être
considéré comme un anar de droite résume
est tous là d'une formule l'imbécile
veut changer le monde l'intelligent se
contente de vouloir le gérer
les anr de droite comme j'ai dit je
n'aime pas tellement les grandes
idéologies les grands combats collectifs
sont avant de vous des individus ils ont
un côté dandy ce qu'il reste 2 c'est
surtout des personnalités
romanesque fantas très original il y en
a quelques exemples dans la dernière
série du figaro magazine ça va deux
blondes à à denis tillinac en passant
par michel audiard ceux qui restent les
nerfs de droite plutôt que de grands
combats idéologiques ce sont de belles
oeuvres littéraires et politiques et
poétiques et je crois que c'est aussi
comme ça qu'on fait progresser la
société l'humanité